this video is sponsored by one of my
personal favorite Services rocket money
more on them after the reaction
[Music]
people hello there citizens of the
reject Nation after loving the last
episode for Monarch I'm excited to see
what's in store for the finale after
that Cliffhanger John are you ready to
get your canar on I can't wait GE that's
what I'm talking about Kon canaro
um that was the greatest thing I don't
care who didn't like that intro last
episode that was the best intro ever
anyway guys uh for listen Apple Spotify
thank you for being here and uh if you
are stick through this intro cuz I'm
going to say leave a like on this video
for our YouTube viewers also uh
subscribe click the notification Bell
for other Jazz stuff that comes up here
that's a terminology thank you to
prepper for helping us Ed down these
highlights and the fooling through at
your watch Al single with your own copy
of mon that is available for a super
sexy rejects over at our patreon page
thank you so much to everyone who has
joined us for Monarch and all the other
shows John and I cover several things
exclusively over there with highlights
and watch songs included John yes let's
get it Shan let's do
[Music]
it who are you all
right I can't really answer that right
now can you
walk have you fired a boat before those
creatures are very Territorial and we
are in their territory
now yep good ready that's how that [__]
Works were you expecting someone else I
wasn't expecting to be alive you're in
heaven what's your name I'm Kate and my
brother's
canar you may have heard our theme song
we fell my God me we have to find the
people I came with is Billy with you
Bill
Randa we have to find them we will calm
down I mean you might find Sha this
way did you listen to what she asked you
yeah did you hear did question Kate did
you pay
attention to access to Hollow
Earth
damn dude working right against
Lea something he
rejected it's true that's why I had two
families it was all part of my
plan
Maps
good luck with that we've been chipping
away at that block for
centuries cuff him Shake him
away what a great way to avoid a
question it's a wonderful Monarch CLA
it's a live again I mean you're a
terrible father Yes like you're just a a
really bad
dad rest of your rescue party follow my
beacon there's only one place they can
come out I've been down here for 2 weeks
yeah don't to be an
Archer what signal you're not part of a
rescue party are you you didn't expect
to find me here you don't even know who
I am you're an not Monarch who are you
I'm
[Music]
Miranda oh my God
God yes come on make it official he is
that really you of course it is did they
get Wyatt Russell do the voice there
sounded like him it's me K it's Lee
right behind this tree come out where I
can see you no no just stay stay there
for a second oh a there's some things
you need to understand how long do you
think you've been down here okay 40
minutes my estimation 57 days days yes
how much time passes per day I came down
here too okay after you fell I let a
recon mission you were here how you
didn't tell me came down here in
1962 I thought I was here for only a
week or so and then I was able to get
right back up I escaped it was 1982 that
was a week back then that was 33 33
years ago oh
wow man she is so good I love her she's
great MVP aside from the mom oh the
gravitational Distortion some Waring of
space the
realization is it
2015 great math yeah she's a scientist
you always work good with numbers K oh
oh hope she looks disgusted you're old e
old
[Laughter]
guy
I can't believe you're alive oh
[Music]
oh that's
tragic
Billy he's he's gone he died a long time
ago man this is a scene this is tragic
there has never been so much emotion in
a monster vers first movie you're lying
my wife died
here oh he's doing fine he's by me how
do you know how do you know how do you
know who are
you I'm your
[Music]
granddaughter
wow what a weird matter of processing is
how to do in the what a mix of emot 30
seconds Jesus yeah she's she's a
terrif good Tim
Tim what about the signal it is not our
priority right now some someone could be
alive and that is not a
priority my man we are looking at a wave
of Titan events threatening the lives of
7 billion people I'm not peeling off
resources to save three that guy just
looked over like a [__] this was a steak
someone is alive down there and they
might have the answers we need and they
are calling us for help we cannot
pretend that we don't hear him like I
see a Tim look at the map of
Tim Tim my hands are tied then untie
them oh otherwise Shaw was right about
us he was definitely right about you oh
how Monarch went from corrupt to good I
need you to think very carefully about
the next words you're going to say are
you going to take your seat do your job
and help us deal with this crisis nah
unbelievable I reconfigured the EM tube
to send out a directional gamap pul to
that you know where I was so monarch
made it to 1962 they're around even
today bigger than ever that was part of
it oh that's not happy news it is now
20145 yeah we're going to get back into
a whole different version of life and
Society
tell me about him he's a a family man
he's a familyes man when Monarch
wouldn't let him he did it on his own he
never knew when to stop except when to
stop being a dad can you rewire this
back to its original configuration I
think so in that case I'm going to take
you home yeah how so I'm going to carry
you over the threshold she wouldn't have
been able to figure that out herself
yeah I don't know that's a seems like
she would V
one oh damn he's moving
out
ouch in such a polite
[Music]
way
MVP in it man I will give him money
yes and I'll call on his birthday
maybe keep me out of
it now I got to start up a whole new
second
family he married both
yes you know jurisdictions
different damn
it you would need four people to carry
it though we can all use a breather
works for
me man Wyatt and Kurt had to fall in
love with the same woman I know hey
seriously don't go far ah they're so
alike it's a call back they're meant to
be that's where that's first oh what
the the meat
cutees can tar would have heard him be
let in apparently like do like a whole
callbo thing to do it he's just so
wrapped up in his drawing not uh not
usually a big whiskey guys what are you
doing here oh come on the Gamay bursts
we found the coherent
signal what am I supposed to do with it
I don't know what what any of this means
no you don't what your bloodline does
but your father might yeah do you know
where we might find him now okay I got
to tell you you look exactly as you've
always looked in my mind's
eye why aren't you
happy come on give us a kiss love I've
been talking to you and Billy in my head
the whole time I was here who you were
anyway way oh she's studying his face
what happened to Billy gained some
weight turn into John good I guess he
was leading an expedition to some Island
and name the island trying to prove some
of the theories about all this and uh he
he never came back he died
unceremoniously oh [__] yes and we've
been trying to make up for that ever
since but he did it K he was the last
man standing he saved Monarch he saved
everything you and he built everything
the three of us built a you were always
the Third Wheel Lee yeah a man that is
hard I love how they're having two very
different experiences I've lost so much
time
Lee worst 57 odd days 58 days what's it
like now
2015 even the words sound fantastic
fantastic yeah coming out of the 1950s
jeez yeah cars are smaller more
efficient nowhere near is cool TV sets
are bigger
fat oh hey we went to the moon of course
I missed that one too because I was down
here but you
know same old world it ain't you babe
same people conflicts triumphs damn Kurt
Russell's been killing it you know
moms dads kids he didn't get to have any
of that either
yeah oh way she looks at him man well
speaking of kids I guess I should check
in on ours
huh ours you may never forgive me for
what I took from you and I can't go back
in time and fix all the mistakes I made
but maybe I could leave something for
the future a legacy of
monsters Tim what are you doing here can
we come
in reveal yes and I have no interest in
working with monac that's probably good
because they wouldn't touch you with a
10-ft
pole Gamay bursts coming from inside the
Rifts I'm well aware of gamma emissions
not these hey there is a coherent signal
in there s o s how by what by who he
thinks Kate could be alive I I mean
Grandma it's impossible it's not
impossible Shaw came back and the rest
of the team didn't the variables are
nearly
infinite yeah Fair quit delaying this
come on we're on the final freaking
episode go hosi come on you said you
wanted me to work with you fine I'm in
but first help me find my sister to be a
family yeah we can all go live in San
Francisco now Monarch won't help no with
something like this they won't and
that's why I quit oh Monarch isn't the
only game in town I work for Apex now
why does it look so much like Earth
because it is parts are It Anyway
different pieces of Home different
pieces of their world the last the most
of the Season feel like these last two
episodes yeah I
know axis
Monday p and have any Earth no ax Mundy
or did we enter the r at
home but welcome to it
Alice wow we're almost there let's keep
moving but you're still contained within
something
science this is Hall earth right i'
unless they're just going to surprise us
with another another realm inside the
Earth yeah cuz I feel like this Journey
has been about how they've been able to
access Hollow Earth
yeah that is our ride come on let's
go they're in love she looks like she
doesn't want to go back yeah she doesn't
want to have to
age got to be kidding me hey this is
amazing isn't it it's only been a few
days 53 years and it still got juice
it's only been here a few weeks
yeah all right let's get these things
wired up and get the hell out of
here you've got more pep in your step
than when you were younger yeah I got it
I know how to finish it I've got this
hey stop I've got this hey what is wrong
with I'm staying behind why oh yeah
Billy's gone my boy cor up without me I
am not going to BR his life again by
reappearing suddenly uh well what's
wrong with this family I know just just
go be together Christ these monsters
have taken everything from me no more
this curse is broken you still have work
to do up there this show is dictating
its Arc
yes and we need you we need you for
Godzilla X Kong eventually wish Kate
would acknowledge that that's I mean um
what Mo and get out of here Grand okay
okay yeah exactly Grand like you're
talking about your son but yo you're
granddaughter's right here right in
front of you
dude I know you just met but also I'm
assuming this flight doesn't have drink
service nope but when we get back first
round's on me huh going to counter
Godzilla trying to prevent them kind of
seems like old times huh straight for
yourself let's go home I love the
contrast of their performances just
makes so much sense that they have two
different experiences it's very
multi-layer best scene work of the
entire show that thing starts blipping
it means the device is lur a Titan
that'll open the the rift and that's our
way home but how do we take off just
hang
on this taller wiard hits 3,000 ft I'll
shut the device off the Titans Retreat
will pull us
in there he is what if they all die
right now what do you see a [__] we
leared a Titan that was already
here where's Godzilla yeah fight Let
Them
Fight
give me my big
lizard come on this be the first time CT
Sees God so what do we do running out of
time and we're not going to get another
shot keep ringing that dinner
bell help them out
goira
o
yeah no someone's got to go out there
it's leaving it's going away from us
[__] what are you doing my job yeah Dam
it no no no no
no what are you doing punch it in the
face this would be such a
[Music]
bummer oh my God come on come
on come on Doc yeah come on
Doc
come on get that lightning
strike easy he get back
here feel like uh setting up the wires
to be that taut was probably not a great
choice when you were arranging all
this that is scary come on
man that is really
scary where to go Doc Brown come
on goir where are
you here we go come on come
on great shot that shot Kur
Russell must have sent a signal to
Callum that looks like yeah
Oh shot D that's a great shot
nice oh
cool that's great get out of my
house get off my lawn oh my God we're
getting a Kaiu
fight you had to do it oh my God nice
camera too oh damn
sweet oh and the glowing eyes oh
e that's my trick
man oh great yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
oo oh oh my what is that going to do it
like a Vortex within a
Vortex get in there come on Lee God damn
it
please
no this would suck so
much come on
T this would suck so much no come on
pull him too
much
uh for
[Music]
[Applause]
everything that's a real bummer
yeah after she just lost everything St
in outside of her granddaughter and Son
yes don't worry we'll have to come back
here for him in season
two
make eye
contact it's great shot out the bar
[Music]
Point why am I not liking the vibe here
yeah I mean cuz this is obviously some
kind of containment and or
[Music]
observation wow we've waited decades for
something exciting to happen right yeah
we had this helipad built and we didn't
even know what
for oh
and I thought it was just like the same
people they maybe it's Apex you did all
this me no I don't understand most of
them but we were lucky someone had
already done a lot of the math you
freaking me now
daddy
dad
a he thought you were
dead break down man go to
her wow he's older than her now
[Music]
yeah that is sad
that
happens oh she's she is so good yeah
she's the best one she is the
MVP oh look at him me cradle like a
boy it's so it's like so mother and
son you know being Asian myself I'm
always being told Asian moms aren't that
expressive and emotional but
I see two very emotional moms in this
show it's true canaro I'd like you to
meet our grandmother our grandmother I
hate to interrupt but we'd like to get
you into medical and debriefing yeah
what this way what are you doing here
well someone had to pay for all of this
Tim what have you done are you working
with her now it's complicated I would
have rather stayed down there
take us back A lot's changed in the past
two years two years wow
2017 what the hell is going on only
everything I ever promised
you oh season 2 supposed to overlap with
king of the monsters I guess Skull
Island research station
baby oh that's how they got Kong over
here wow yeah that's how they got Kong
wow
[Music]
that's
cool yeah that's really cool
yeah nice shot that's a really cool tie
in I did wonder how they got Kong yeah
that was a question but Monarch had Kong
yeah we'll have to go back Apex we'll
have to go back and do a chronological
rewatch with all 10 episodes of Monarch
included yeah to really understand
what's going on Kate
andaro Kate and
canaro Tim thank you to Rocket money for
sponsoring this video a brand that I am
happy to be partnered with thrilled to
it's fortunately one that I have been
using for quite a while now prior to
ever agreeing to a partnership with them
I was like that makes for the best kind
of synergy promotion because I can
actually talk about them from my heart
here reason being like many you guys of
like for years I am constantly
downloading all kinds of financial apps
that I keep forgetting to use or I don't
really find quite as beneficial rocket
money has been the one the only one I'm
not just saying it is the only one that
I have been able to consistently use
rely on that has been an absolute game
Cher for me on a very personal note
running real rejects is an absolute
privilege however you know like I stress
out about taxes and it's the beginning
of the year and I'm like I'm trying to
be smarter and get it all done now I
already started like a couple months ago
getting things in order managing real
rejects finances while managing my own
personal finances has been an ongoing
struggle and I'm very big on like
efficiency and being organized but
clearly it wasn't as good enough as I uh
thought I had been so before rocket
money came into my life I was drowning
in subscriptions and struggling to keep
track of my expenses and as I really
wanted to like get everything in order
rocket money came at the right time for
me I was overwhelmed with subscriptions
I didn't even know I had or had still
been subscribed to I mean do you ever
wonder how many subscriptions you
actually pay for have you ever taken the
time to really do it it could be a
little daunting rocket money helped me
see what I was missing and best part
they even canceled those subscriptions
for me with just a simple tap so with
rocket money you can have all your
subscriptions in one place making it
easy to cancel anything unnecessary
without the hassle of dealing with
customer service my so annoying plus
they'll work on getting you refunds and
negotiate lower bills saving you up to
to 20% you just snap a pick of your bill
and let rocket money take care of the
rest let me just summarize for you
really quick what they are they're a
personal finance app that findes and
cancels unwanted subscriptions monitors
your spending and helps lower your bills
with over 5 million users and over $500
million in cancel subscriptions they've
already saved members an average of $720
a year they' helped save me a little bit
more than that don't waste your hard
earn money on unused subscriptions
cancel them today at Rocket money.com
rejects that's rocket money.com rejects
if you've heard other people people talk
about them well use ours Rocky money.com
rejects cuz if you use that promo code
rejects you unlock special benefits and
yes using them is also a great way to
support the channel same time it's just
a great way to support your bank account
cuz I cannot stress enough just how much
this app has changed the game form me
take control of your finances with
rocket money and enjoy Financial Peace
of Mind all righty guys well if you
listening to us on Apple and Spotify
please rate this video and if you're
watching us on YouTube I've got to ask
ask why have you not shelv out your
hard-earned dollars and used it to put
into a Shopify account in order to pay
for some real reject merch at reject
naations shop.com hey you know they'd
say that when you earn money it's wise
to invest and sometimes investing in
yourself and how you feel and look and
also your seventh or eighth favorite
YouTube channel is the best of
Investments to better your mental health
to make you more productive in life and
getting any one of these shirts would do
just that for you reation shop.com thank
you to all who have supported us all
right well John just watched Monarch
Legacy of Kaden canaro truly and um I
thought that this
was I don't think it's objectively the
best episode I would say it's
my I mean you can't really qualify
anything as objective right uh and this
I I I feel like there's parts of my
brain that go no I think the last
episode was the best one I was easily
the
most emot this is the first one that got
me emotional about [__] agree you know
and it only took like 10 episodes to get
there but I I finally got emotional
about like I found I really felt the
emotions here and this gave me some of
my absolute favorite scenes this might
be my favorite I think if you're going
to end the show they ended it strong and
it might be my favorite episode of them
all there's like more of like the sci-fi
horror s qualities and mystery and stuff
that looks like other Apple TV shows
I've heard good things about that feel a
little like Westworld that of the last
episode I really love but yeah I was
very pulled into this uh pretty much
from beginning to end because I was
actually really invested in the
characters this time and everyone's uh
interactions and Kay and
Shaw like their scene work together was
mesmerizing to me it was it was the most
dynamic and the the sadness that had
been overcome and the joy in Shaw's
performance but also like the
realization and pain of not realizing oh
my God how much time I've lost in like
the amount of processing and having to
survive like there was there was so much
uh multiple layers occurring throughout
each of their
performances of like of course she's
relieved to see him but she's also like
so sad and he's just so happy to see her
and he feels like he can finally die and
like like him dying being willing to let
go just to keep her alive just to just
to break her out of there I'm like I
believe that that he would let her go
it's a bummer as an audience member I
was like man I was really bummed by that
because I wanted him to give like a big
Fu to everyone yeah they really needed
that and Godzilla showed up so you know
it's the best one yeah well he's going
to be back don't worry next season he's
coming back they got to go back and find
him yeah I love how Godzilla just showed
up I know like what is going on did you
call my name over here opening happening
here and uh I didn't I didn't authorize
this portal here even there's a bunch of
us I just like to show up at the nick of
time that's a good King right there
always aware of what's happening in his
kingdom like let
fight we do that's what we do Titan's
fight yeah let them much them all they
want civil not much civility to the
Titans no they're's big animals and just
fight yeah just fight just a ready to
rumble fight and eat and fight world
it's a beautiful ready to rumble world
of fantasy yeah yeah exactly we should
all be so lucky you like it kiry
clemenson to make out with with Kate
yeah so this show is is homophobic uh I
think because of that uh now I hated
this episode I would agree I would agree
with everything you just said I think
yeah the previous episode is probably I
would argue like the best one in terms
of being well-rounded and having the
kind of tonal Intrigue that you would
hope for it makes you want to follow
that Rabbit Hole uh this episode by
comparison does have beats that feel
because it's the finale a bit brief or
or kind of rushed or shortlived uh but I
would certainly agree that this had the
best most interesting emotional beats
that required something that sort of
like
transcends most of what I associate with
the show uh and so yeah to find
ourselves in a couple of scenes having
to process time dilation having to
process uh you know the slowing of age
and the passing of time and and and all
this chaos and Madness and Monarch and
Legacy and family like all all the
different layers and shades and just the
way that that they're looking at each
other and the way Kay is like studying
his face during their scenes together
because he is different now but still
spiritually the same guy like yeah there
was I think that's why it was great to
actually cast this was when I was like
it was so smart to cast w getting hurt
absolutely was because that makes that
exceptionally more believable yeah it's
like I wish this I wish this would have
started in episode nine and like or or
gotten there or or
sooner any yeah in its current most
current iteration I wish we started
getting those kinds of moments that made
this episode shine at least in the
previous episode because I can
understand being like well you know
we'll save K till the end or something
to to finally reunite or whatever like
it's cool to have her do the catniss
thing at the end of the last episode but
I feel like that could have happened at
the end of the previous episode if we
finagled a little bit and then really
like I would have loved to have spent
some time just down here with them for a
whole episode and you could have had
enough to do with you feel that loss of
like damn how much time have they lost
and you're wondering yeah and never cut
back to Earth because then we don't know
and and that would be pretty interesting
and and I like the twist at the end of
like oh man it's been another two years
and and continuing that emotionality
through to her reuniting briefly with
Hiroshi and you know at least getting
the whole like canaro is here too he's
your grandson yeah like all those things
yeah like she is just such a terrific
terrific actress and she has been across
this and every moment of hers has
typically brought with it the kind of
emotionality and the kind of impact I
think you hope a show like this could
deliver across the boort yeah and uh
yeah like I think that once we start
getting to the point where they're
exiting and and things are happening
with Kurt Russell and and you're drawing
him into Jeopardy that's when I start to
feel like the choice itself is
appropriate the
execution is good in the moment but
feels rushed over all which is a bummer
because when you get these glimpses of
things that are like truly you just see
through the veil and you see the moments
where the show is working ideally and
then you're like okay know you're
capable of doing this and now I wish
that you had taken more of that nuance
and flavor and and you know noting the
previous episode some of that sci-fi
horror strangeness and really yeah
peppered it through the entire season
because once we finally get to Hollow
Earth like it starts to feel
appropriately kind of expanded and then
you think back on the first few episodes
and it just felt like we were spinning
so many Wheels by like running around
the world but saying about bunch of the
same dialogue when we get there and then
moving on again yeah uh so yeah this is
like a maddening episode because of the
great qualities of it almost um but yeah
you get your cool Kaiju fight and uh
we're home Bob's your uncle you're
requisite Kaiju you're very very like
very requisite didn't need it but you
know you kind of do cuz yeah cuz it's a
monarch it's Legacy of monsters with
Godzilla tie in and just use just have
them show up this is literally the [__]
that people complain about in like Star
Wars shows and uh the other franchises
you know marvel whatever when like sure
it's just a cameo it's like an
unnecessary Cameo yeah it could have
been any Kaiju who who did this when it
happens you're like what we
needed it's weird on the other shows
you're like
come on yes it's like cool but then
you're like yeah come on but here on on
this show in particular like well you
know you need to see the monsters it's
not like I didn't want to see Gods it's
not like I didn't want to see Kong you
know why wouldn't I want a shot you know
yeah totally why wouldn't I but yeah I
think these last two episodes were
undoubtedly the best uh well the 10 one
was pretty great but in terms of the
show that I terms of the show that I
showed up for I would I'm like this is
uh
I think the finale is my favorite one
just on an emotional level and I even
like stuff with Yoshi and canaro and how
complicated that is you know he I like
that after the end of trying to find
him just this I I don't know what the
culture is really like I can't speak to
what Society culture is like and it it
just feels like fractured family that
it's very relatable and in in just that
uh sense and the and the fractured part
with the with the dad of him not being
able to
just let his son in and how how much of
a struggle it is for him because they
they do pay attention I I could still
feel the writing and how they pay
attention to the psychology of the
characters like he has a lot of loss and
abandonment issues at the end of the day
he wasn't technically like they didn't
like abandon him purposefully you know
but that LE what he experienced
leaves a child feeling abandoned and it
would make sense to me why Hiroshi is
the way he is especially with his son of
all people you know like seeing himself
and his son in his own way and how that
also leads to like the divorce with the
mom and how the mom creates a level of
agency and I love the the attention
detail too on her performance of like
this level of politeness that is
probably ingrained with her in her
culture
but also standing up for herself and
making the right choice for her own kid
and this episode pointing out like hey
you know the the legacy of everything
there's uh there's also generational
trauma that occurs and it's about
undoing that now moving forward more
than anything else when Kate said you
know this curse is
broken and then everyone in the theater
stood up and applauded and
ride that that uh that's what this
episode's about really is is is watching
the the shifts there even with the
grandma want K being mean like I I
should like I that was the part though
like I really got it I joke like what's
wrong with this family it it's like I
get it you know like I I would have
liked a little bit of an acknowledgment
of yo you're like right here in front of
your granddaughter though you know like
why you interact her a little bit be on
just asking about how's how's your dad
you know well and yeah and like if she's
going back what she just going to say
like oh we didn't find her yeah or is
she going to say she decided to stay to
spare your feelings sorry she continued
to aband in you yeah she chose it this
time like yeah yeah she's not she's your
granddaughter she's not some woman and
if we had started the emotionality it's
it's like the last two episodes are the
yin and yang of like the second to last
episode has all the the cool all the
action oriented stuff and the tone you
want around that is there and then this
episode has all the emotional stuff and
the atone around that is there and if
you could just merge the two because
then you know if we had gotten to here
earlier we could have actually lived in
that moment instead of having it be like
a quick you know oh it kind of reminded
me of like a dial of Destiny thing cuz I
think the writing is like in terms of
like the actual sci-fi [__] that goes on
in terms of the plot of Monarch is is
more interesting in the last episode
like here every scene with Tim is
there's a signal yeah know this is
leading to I'm going to go to canaro
there's a signal going to go to Yoshi
there's a signal that's how so much of
the writing on the show has next next
the sign work hey we got him yeah and
and and they're chasing something that
we've already really know the
circumstances of yeah so I did get to a
point of like just [__] just act on
the signal just go just do it just spend
some time on something different yeah
I'll trade back my precious Tim time for
some better drama that just watching him
spin wheels but the thing is though is
like this the scene workor though be I I
really feel like it's just because of
the scene workor with K and
Shaw that alone I'm like I've never seen
so much like I've never felt so much
emotion generated from this show in
terms of like I am really getting in the
fields here for what's happening and I
am very much impressed and and this NE
and this scene only exists because of a
Sci-Fi realm you know like it it only
works on the Sci-Fi realm of
how like I think that makes it feel so
much more lived in with the drama like
they both seem so believable in this and
there's so much Nuance happening here oh
yeah uh it just a wide pallet of
emotions and and and then even when you
get to Hiroshi in her at the end I'm
like damn that is very emotional I don't
even like this
guy but I feel for both of them here now
and I can see it's like having Loop you
know yeah it's like you can see all the
things that led to all these you know
all of his transgressions laid bare in
that moment and and that you know is is
yeah it bridges that Gap at least in the
immediate moment of you know the stuff
about hoshi's character that is
frustrating yeah yeah in that moment it
it feels understandable
and you get I feel like the show has
done a
relatively mid to poorish job of of
making you see from his perspective
because uh you know just the way they
handle the character for the sake of
mystery I don't know it kind of bungles
that but for but in that moment and like
I don't mind a character that we can get
intimate with while watching them make
you know difficult and or you know bad
decisions but uh I don't know yeah it
was nice to feel for that here and to
have the emotionality to bolster the
logic you know is true but that isn't
the drama of the show you know
I surprisingly came
around on a level of characters I really
disliked watching canaro easily was
number
one undoubtedly number one and then I
went it it was canaro yeah behind canaro
was Kate behind Kate was kiry Clemens
was May May so went 321 for me like that
that was like kiry Clemens was three
canaro didn't just go from three to what
canaro like went like oh my God I really
like canaro now yeah and that and that
through line stayed in this episode I'm
like I really I still really like was in
like a oneoff
episod yeah his scenes are good I love
it like the Dynamics are given him are
very interesting I really like him and
and like that was probably the biggest
shocker like one episode just
slingshotted like oh my God I actually
really I hate you were like my least
favorite people uh and Kate never really
like she had better scenes here but uh
Kate and and may I'm like they they can
easily not return next season they
didn't write for them yeah they they
didn't write much of anything for those
characters and I mean like in terms of
like the female characters they did a
great job with K uh like she's the
probably the one of easily the best
perform she might be prob the best
character yeah she might be the best
terms of both character and performance
and all the stuff that goes into it uh
Cano's mom is great uh who runs monor
she's enjoyable Verdugo yeah she's
enjoyable I think she for for what that
role is she does a qu quality job she's
enjoyable when you put her in a scene
with Tim which is all her scenes yes
outside of a couple of scenes that are
not with Tim yeah bad and and I like
badass lady who hasn't been here for a
minute yeah yeah she's fine she's fine
um uh but yeah the Kate I did not really
come around to I I I don't feel like
they know how to I liked her scene when
she when she said I'm your granddaughter
or something like that like that was a
good emotional moment yeah uh and and
like I said she had better scenes here
overall but I never really came around
her character and I kept trying in my my
mind and heart I kept
trying and I just couldn't and uh may
she had that one Apex Tim
episode it was weird it was like a B I
thought the way how I was concerned
about my association with canaro that
was like this is just one episode
because that's how it was for May for me
I was like Ba's great in this episode
was just the one well and that's that's
so much of what has happened with again
it's a I think a flaw of the show where
you will have these like moments of
intense Focus that don't feel connected
to everything else uh cuz I mean yeah we
got a whole episode on Kate and I feel
like the point of doing that was just to
somehow justify this random romance
that's now happening that also doesn't
seem to be something they really care
that much about like I'll take detail
details where you don't have to put them
over no details where you don't have to
put them but like this this relationship
that they have forming
like one part of my brain is like in
theory it's kind of cool that I guess
this romance can just kind of happen and
it's just like a little thing they keep
peppering in with like body language or
like little gestures but at the same
time it also feels
like it's just sort of like a happen
stance that it made it in here like
you're I don't know like life can feel
like happens dance but when you're
making art or Cinema or a show or
whatever you got to put a lot of thought
into that and I feel like there was
little to no thought put into that so
it's one of those it doesn't make me mad
because again these are madeup
characters that can do whatever they
want but at the same time it does feel
like one of those things where it's like
this is a cool choice to have made could
you could you focus on or maybe pepper
it with anything could you give me
anything to care about with this because
you know they've been brought together
maybe was the character who like I don't
even want to be I don't want to be
brought on this Advent she was kind of
like just along for the ride at the
beginning of the journey MH and like
there experiences again I I always just
think back to that one moment where
they're in the cave and Kate's having
that uh PTSD moment in like episode
three or whatever when they're exploring
the radiation Zone uh and like that is
about the only moment I could think of
that like is intimate between them for
any reason and now they have this whole
like unspoken thing which again is like
like it's cool in
isolation but it's not really it doesn't
feel like it's been made part of those
characters and it feels like the most
significant thing that's happened to
Kate in recent aside from being a
sidekick on the Lee Shaw Adventure is
this romance and it feels like this sort
of weird just I don't know additional
addendum they just like taped to the
side yeah or something like that and her
performances again it's like I don't
even even really feel I don't know what
it is cuz I don't feel like it's the
actor again but I can also feel like in
those moments in this episode that we
more emotional like even the way they're
shooting her isn't that intimate the
dialogue that they give her the scenes
they give her aren't that prolonged or
in depth or anything so I just feel like
the show treated her with such a
pedestrian gaze and never really except
for that one episode again and except
for the early moments of the PTSD
cutting in like even that trailed off
and doesn't really feel like part of her
charact she's just like peppy now and
that's fine but she doesn't really feel
like an actual character no but overall
um I don't know what I'd give this show
out of 10 I'll give it
a uh
70% for Goodwill give it a like a
6.8 sure why not I don't give [__] 6
point I like the finale it's great all
right solid finale overall uh what do
you guys think of Monarch you want to
season two what would you want to
explore I actually feel like there'd be
more personality if Apex was here the
whole time sure just because I love the
silly ass cheese it brings um leave your
thoughts down below subscribe leave a
like and let's end this with a
p Brian Perry it's 2024 we've entered
the dawn of shout outs for Brian Perry
and now we got to kick it off properly
with figuring out what your New Year's
resolution is going to be this year my
friend and I feel like your New Year's
resolution will be to make your bed
every morning oh it's a good one it's a
great one I think making your bed every
morning clears your mind helps you feel
like you accomplish a task for the day
and if I know you Brian Perry and I
think I do you probably sleep in the
nude yes and when you sleep in the nude
sometimes as a guy I get it you're
probably really hairy might leave a
little bit of a mark uhoh little brown
Mark silhouette just in little hairs or
that or a poop mark yeah poop mark yeah
I went first you got a yes s so poop
Mark was there poop mark with hair on it
poop mark with hair on it and when you
make your bed you can cover that [__] up
literally you can and then no one will
notice was there and I've been like dude
maybe your resolution this year should
be to buy some brown sheets some Black
Sheets maybe the uh crystaline White is
not really cutting for you and maybe not
even a fabric maybe some kind of vinyl
you know yeah and then next year 2025
you can buy some better toilet paper in
a bedet three my friend that might work
as well so um you're the second Patron I
have made a poop reference to and I feel
like it's going to be an ongoing theme
now it's the poop month for
sh what creative way will you poop so
Brian my friend uh make your bed every
morning uh seriously it'll help uh uh
Free Your Mind of a of a lot of of a lot
of uh you know people say it does
something for you it's a placebo effect
it's a bunch of [__] it's like
writing your name on the paper to get
points a it's not really going to do
anything it's like when you add some
[__] onto your to-do list to make
you feel like oh wow I'm ahead of the
day some people say you shouldn't even
make your bed cuz it's going to move all
the particulates around and attract bed
bugs and things like that you should
just leave it that's why John has bed
[Music]
bugs